I wanted to kick off with a question
that I had on my own and that is you
know it sounds like the model even you
know there were these four scenarios
where you showed these sort of like
curves and it's even with the social
district social distancing you still see
a resurgence of the disease sort of down
the road like closer to December those
curves were still coming up later on so
do you mind going back to that slide
just so everybody can visualize it cuz
I'm here yeah so curbs three and four
right so that those are with the strict
social distancing measures you know are
those is it I guess my question is like
is is around you know what is the value
of social distancing now if you're only
gonna see those Peaks take place but
just at a later date so that's that's a
really great point I guess one of the
key values is that if you can delay it
enough you can give government's more
time to respond and something we also
didn't mention is you can give
researchers more time to start looking
into different therapeutics maybe start
and looking for vaccines so that's one
thing you get more time to prepare so
that when it does eventually come around
you you may have a better outcome
because you are more prepared but
another probably an important assumption
about this paper is it when that
resurgence happens they don't implement
any new social distancing measures or
any new kind of control measures and so
they just let things play out but in
reality what would probably happen is
that once you start to see peace again
you may have governments that start to
put more restrictions back in place just
to try and keep things a little bit
under control
great thank you so I think that was a
really important like fine time I think
is the key yeah that makes that makes
complete sense okay and with that I
think we'll start going into some of the
questions that our audience submitted
both through zoom and Facebook and we
have a first question was who that was
submitted by Rosalee here on Zoom and
she says that this feels that they're
changing two variables at once by adding
different types of SD by changing times
as well why did not do one at a time and
for the same amount of time before
varying that the time does that make
sense
um yeah I think so here for example for
curve three and four it's actually the
same social dismantling rules but they
implemented time by saying for the this
third case we're gonna stop at the end
of March and the other one is going to
be at the end of April
so they actually I don't if answer the
question but it's like for the same
social distancing rules but with a
different time on the end of so they
changed they don't change them at the
same time they change them in each group
so you know the difference between three
to one are the increasing amount of
social distances and then the difference
between three and four is the time
they're not being changed at the same
time yeah it's just it's this line but
she met presented words it's the same
social distancing rules but one is just
ending one months after the other so in
that industry if you compare this to
scenarios you're still comparing the
same social distancing measures but what
happens if we keep it we could do and
between two and three for example the
time also they change a bit or was that
not true yeah so in between two and
three days Summa we keep the social
distancing measures on one additional
month and we're even more strict by also
adding this general social distancing so
it's in between two and three you're
like jumping a lot because you're adding
one month of measures and they're even
stricter yeah and I think that was the
most II at the problem that Rosalie was
alluding to is that in that particular
jump you're actually changing a lot of
variables at one yeah and actually what
you can see from the result is by having
more strict social distancing measure
you can here you see you decrease the
value of the peak so the number of
infected people you're gonna have at the
peak but if you just delay by one month
by keeping the same measures you're
gonna have the same value just dealing
yeah so the time just delays it but the
amount of social distance distance in
the asher's reduces the number of yeses
that make sense yeah and I also think
it's worth noting
that you know when we think about
experimental evaluation and like a
laboratory setting it's a very
controlled environment when we talk
about public house none none of our
lives is happening in a controlled
situation or in a vacuum and I think
that makes the data a little messy just
inherently because of the fact that you
can't control for there's no control for
human life right and so we all do what
we're gonna do so I think you know for
these types of data it's it's tricky
overall okay so we have a question from
Anissa and the question is what happens
and people come out too early
and how does removing restrictions to
white sort of explained here in this in
this but maybe you can go through it for
any church yeah so is once you release
these restrictions is when people start
moving about as normal again and they
can come into contact with each other
just as much as they could before those
those rules were put in place and so you
have the contact rate among people
starts increasing again and like we
showed that means that the transmission
rate will increase and that's why you
get you can get another increase in in
cases so for example the you know the
orange or the yellow lines here the
rules were taken out and it did take a
while for the cases to increase again
but you do see it was later you see that
second wave because there's there's no
more control measures in place okay
great and third question from annsofi
who is asking eagle-eye dense if he is
asking why the curve what the strictest
model looks initially higher than the
others I'm not sure that it no I think
initially higher like before it goes
down I guess there's a little bleep
there in January oh I see that's
probably before the measures start
getting put in place but I don't know if
Chloe should you want to address that
yeah so that as well as faltered but I
think what's actually happening is it's
more of a clotting issues so I think the
orange line and the yellow line are
probably on top of each other and what
you're just yellow line because yes
before those the measures were in place
so everything
happening the same in those two
scenarios so it's just that you can't
see the line below it great thanks so
fun I was wondering if we could
elaborate on the impact of kids so they
had trouble understanding the logic
behind why more cases would be averted
if children
I guess if there was social distancing
incorporated for schools and nurseries
but it's I guess the assumption that one
is making is that children are less
infectious is that maybe can you
elaborate on that a little bit yeah so
the assumption they make in the paper
actually is that people who are
symptomatic or less infectious because
they assume that if you have less
interest and you're less likely to
transmit the easies which may not be
true but that's an assumption that they
make and so they assume not because we
haven't observed that many cases of
children then children are more likely
to be asymptomatic and so they're more
likely to be less infectious so that's
what happens in this graph and so you
avoid more cases because you have less
transmission for example occurring in
the household so by kicking people home
even if you close the school you still
have interactions between adults and
children in the households and if you
drain are less infectious then less
diseases to the adults are on them or
the other children around them so I
think that's why they avoid more cases
and you can also avoid more cases in the
older people because it's likely that
sometimes you know children live with
their grandparents or things like that
and so you can still avoid cases and one
thing that I should mention is that at
the end of the social distant thing
people go back to normal so the kids
still go to school and you can still
have transmission so if if children are
less infections in this transmission in
the school it is make it less likely to
happen I guess okay I think we have a
question now about your actual work from
Lauren who loves calculus and who's
wondering if and how you use calculus in
your work
you wanna I can I can set quickly so
basically what we do is or whatever what
I've done previously is instead of
looking at people we look at cells and
so we use the same type of models that
we're looking at cells in your body and
for example when you are infected by a
virus cells are acting in your body to
react to the virus and a lot of things
are happening and we could look at the
dynamic of the cells is the same or we
can look at dynamics of people and we're
trying to understand those dynamics with
mathematical models so I would agree I
think clearly described it really well
and just add that you know there's lots
of options depending what you're
interested in you can use very similar
models to look at the spread of diseases
you can look at sales becoming infected
you can also look at things like
population growth you can look at animal
movements there's so many different
things that you can do with math but I
don't think I was really aware of until
I was the one started studying it when I
was older so I think it's really great
interested now and there's lots of
things you can do with it so adding on
to Lauren's question if a person is
interested in maybe learning how to do
this type of modeling either because
they just have an interest or maybe you
want to do this you know as an education
and career what types of maps do you
think they should try to hone in on is
Catholic for example is calculus more or
less valuable than say statistics you
know as people who come from those
backgrounds in your training what what
arm of math was started the most
valuable for you
for me I have a background in
mathematics like basic mathematics and
then when I started trying to apply into
health I realized I really needed
biostatistics and statistics so I would
not neglect that but I'm a little bit
biased because I have a PhD in
biostatistics so maybe I'm gonna tell
you that but some other people will tell
you something else but I think it's
great to have the first background in
mathematics and be interested in
biological questions there's always a
way to find a master degree that does
add a bit more applied mathematics and
then you will find a lot of people who
are interested in your skills to try and
understand and help understanding
biological informatics or you know even
informatics is really useful so keep
going that direction yeah my background
is mapped to and I really wish I'd taken
more statistics but also a computer
coding is something that I think what ku
and I use all the time I probably do
that more now than I use my actual math
knowledge so if you could there's any
way you can expose yourself to more
computer coding that's also a great a
great skill to have it's so interesting
that you're separating statistics from
math because the thing I would consider
them sort of statistics under the
umbrella so are you saying that they're
different we can we did talk about that
later but yeah that's really interesting
all right let's get back to the paper so
that we make sure everybody's questions
get answered so here's a question from
Peggy and this is coming from Facebook
and it's around starting school in
September do you think that you know our
people when people are applying these
models I guess maybe for a woman or or
even places in the united states like
new york do you think you know opening
up schools in September is going to
impact any of this what are the models
saying I didn't start answering an Amish
name I think we need more information
unfortunately I don't think we can
project now that's actually why the
Columbia team is only projection like in
eight weeks
because a lot of things are changing
whether it be the behavior of people or
the policies or like a lot of things so
we need more information we also need
more information on how many people are
actually infected in the country or in
New York City so we need more testing
and that will also give us a better idea
of you know how much the disease has
spread in the city yet and based on this
information maybe we can reevaluate for
the situation in September but I think
you know it's too early
okay all right we'll move on to the next
one then and this is a little bit
outside of the scope of this paper but I
still think we can discuss this from
Aileen who you know in your in your
model two different conditions that
people could have in the model that was
discussed you mentioned that people
could not were not in fashion infectious
once they had recovered and Aileen was
wondering if that had been determined
because she thought it was she thought
it was unknown so it's it's very true I
would say there is it's unknown how long
people are infectious for so you know
model they assume it's on average a week
but it you know it could go up to maybe
two weeks that's so definitely unknown
but and the idea that you know the way
we just find recovered is that you're no
longer infected and infectious so the
the definition of recovered to say that
you know once you are in that recovered
phase you are definitely not going to
transmit the disease anymore but she's
absolutely right there's there is there
is unknown at what point you will move
into that stage asking you to come in
fact the victim infectious and obviously
then a different question is can people
at that point become infected again but
but I don't think that that was really
included in the models that we were
discussing that's a question for another
paper also for that question I would
refer to a previously for PE that was
speaking about how long immunity lasts
and that's also something that can be
included in the model when we know more
we can also assume that you know
proportion of the population is likely
to be reinfected if it's the case or not
can be adjusted in the model but if you
want to know more good just looking for
people next week luckily that page is
live so people can watch it and engage
with the discussion guide so we can
share that with everybody here ok so we
have another question from Lauren and I
guess this is getting at the seasonal
spread so how does the virus spread
differently when you're insert versus
outside for instance can people spending
less time inside in the summer months to
prevent the virus from spreading so
quickly if you if you know hi so I am
NOT an expert I think a lot of it
depends on what happens to the virus and
the air wants you know some big coughs
or sneezes and how the particles kind of
did disperse but I think the the general
consensus art fault at the moment is
that being eyesight is you know you may
be less at risk because you know
particles have more space to diffuse but
yeah I just not my area of expertise I
was able to say
you
yeah that's a very tough one to answer
but you know I guess there's still
research on going around all of this
but did they know correct me if I'm
wrong but they did determine when SARS
or MERS first came out or those seasonal
by any chance sorry I think at least
four stars it wasn't around long enough
for us to UM tell but first so there are
other human coronaviruses that actually
circulate year-round there so they're
related to the novel coronavirus but
they're the second leading cause of the
common cold so we probably all had them
a lot and those are seasonal in the you
know there are higher higher numbers of
cases in the wintertime but it's you
know so it could be the new stars co2 is
is like that but we just don't have
enough information to tell right now
yeah so it seems like we lost Chloe but
I think we because the only reason is I
was gonna suggest we go back to the to
the slide where you had the graphs for
the next question but I think we can
probably all remember it and the
question is from Aaron and he's he's
saying that the maximum difference
between the peak heights when you
compare scenario one with scenario 4 is
about 20% or less and that the total
area under each curve which is a concept
that you might want to talk about as
well appears to be about the same so he
thinks that this suggests that if
assuming no effective treatment is
developed by December the total number
of death social distance so you don't
have they don't share those exact
numbers in the paper of all the total
number of infections is and so yeah
maybe I should go into the so the total
area under the curve in those graphs so
what the each curve is floating is the
number of new cases each day but if you
were to add up the number of cases on
each day for the whole length of the
time and then that would be the total
number of cases that you get over the
whole period that they're looking at and
so that's essentially what bit
area under the curve this is like all
those cases added up together and so
they they may be very similar I think in
the paper they plot the total number and
they you know at December 2020 right at
the end when they stop their simulations
there is a very slight difference
between some of the curves but it's not
that big and so yeah what that suggests
is that the total number of cases there
isn't much difference between the
scenarios but you know I think the main
point is that you know even if that is
the case it's really important to delay
that peak because if you give people
more time to prepare it may be that in a
couple months time you signed it
therapeutic or youth you know your
hospitals are more prepared so you can
actually have a better impact when it
speaks start so you may actually be a
little bit too pushed I might keep more
than it is portrayed at the moment
assuming that you know everything is the
same yeah exactly
and the maximum number of cases in one
day being slightly lower is obviously
going to make a big difference in the
you know hospital capacity for that day
and as we sort of described before those
Peaks are taking those Peaks are taking
place at a much later date so the hope
is there's just more time for verb or
creative intervention I love this
question from Sophia and the question is
around can researchers use data from the
study to map deaths due to cope at 19
over time so what would be required to
clarify the importance of social
distancing in these models sorry can you
is it about the data that we need to
gather or is it more I guess it would be
effort I think it um you know we're in
such early stages of understanding the
impacts of social distancing right so
what what would help clarify what extra
data or you know variables are needed to
really understand how social distancing
is impact
yeah so I think we've been speaking a
lot about testing in the population
because now at the moment the
observation we have about the people who
were infected is mostly through people
who are going to the hospital so it's
it's definitely useful to have a better
idea of how many people are infected in
the population to better understand how
the virus has been spreading in in the
population I think what some people have
been saying is that we don't have a
control because we don't know what's
happening when this is you know spread
if we don't do the social distancing but
we have seen that countries who haven't
applied social distancing have been
having some issues which is definitely
not a control compared to like what
happening in New York for example but it
gives us insights on also the dynamic of
the epidemic in also this like this
social distancing stuff is something
that we would apply for any other
disease that transmitted by air it's not
just specific to Kobe 19 it's measures
that are being recommended by experts
for a long time and I should know that
something to ask them no I think yeah
yeah so this is a really interesting
question bye-bye Aditi so okay if
individuals are easily infected with the
virus and as we've mentioned that's a
big if and again you know directing
people to to last week's presentation
Thank You Lizzy for sharing the link for
that but let's imagine hypothetically
that if individuals were easily
reinfected with this virus and they
could then be infectious again how would
this affect the are not value and the
peak of the curve is that something that
could be included in the model yeah so
sorry go ahead Kim so the R naught is
not going to be affected the or not is
what happens if the disease spread in
the population that's completely
susceptible so it's something that you
would determine mostly at the beginning
of the epidemic there are the effective
reproductive number the re or RT or R
that Shannon mentioned would definitely
be affected because people would just be
instead of being recovered and not being
able to not being reinfected they will
go back to the susceptible compartment
and so that would definitely affect the
progression of you to make yes it would
increase actually the progression of the
epidemic and we would need a vaccine or
or a treatment to prevent that so I'll
I'll ask the the last question and I'm
just gonna sort of summarized a couple
of the ideas that I seen in our question
chat and it's around the motion to you
know there's a lot of states that are
currently reopening and what we're
finding is you know some of the states
that are currently reopening it didn't
necessarily have very strict social
distancing rules in the first place and
that could be for a variety of different
reasons and as they reopen we're also
seeing things like you know everybody's
going to the beach everybody's going to
a restaurant um you know what what do
you think that's gonna do what do you
think that you know do do you think that
you know are there models that can help
people sort of understand the
consequences of those actions in in
these like granular ways and if so you
know how powers that kind of information
important for policymakers to know and
sort of Congress people to know where do
you see those intersections of the
modelling pieces and the people who are
saying who are making the rules for
society I know that's a little bit of a
loaded question but I would love to hear
your thoughts on that so so personally
I'm a little bit worried about places
opening up too soon because yeah you
know it's cases may look like they're
kind of steady now but there's always a
lag between when things are implemented
and then when we actually start to see
cases turn off a bit hospital because of
the long period between when you start
to show symptoms and so what may look
like is you know things are going okay
right now it could be that in a few
weeks time it's a different story
yeah sorry yes like how are people
engaging with like are people like in
your field for example or your lab group
as an example are they engaging with
policymakers or people that are sort of
getting to say how people behave in a
society or community I'm I would say
that I'm sure at people who are modeling
these things are trying to engage with
policy makers and people at the
government level to try and help plan or
at least I'm sure people are
communicating the results that their
model but then it's up to policy makers
whether they want to implement kind of
the recommendations of the scientists
because obviously there are a lot of
other factors that go into these
decisions and economic factors and you
know lots of other factors so yeah yeah
I imagine it's very tricky yes sir I
know excellent no I was just gonna say
that we've seen decisions that were
based on models like a couple of months
ago in UK some decisions were taken
after the like results from the model
were published or like spread so it's
actually already happening which is
which is good that you know governments
are taking decisions that are based on
science and again as we said the models
are going to be refined by more data and
and because we're learning more about
the disease so hopefully it will help
also in the in the future to take
decisions that are balanced between the
other factors and the number of people
are kind of affected by the disease
yeah thank you and I think with that I
think if anybody is really interested in
science but also interested in public
health and/or policy I hope everybody
out here will consider you know moving
in those aren't like training and
science and then being a part of the
government I mean how amazing it could
have been to cede our government with
people who are who value data and